It pains me to say,
but I've recently arrived
at two conclusions
about myself --
I am not young,
and I am not hip.
[ Light laughter ]
No, it's true.
I mean, I can make
a Cobain joke.
[ Laughter ]
And because I'm not
young and hip,
I often don't know how to feel
about some of the things
that are going on in
our popular culture.
But fortunately for all of us,
I do have people
on my writing staff
who are both of those things,
and nobody on our staff
is younger and hipper than our
good friend, Jeff Wright.
-Thank you, Seth.
It's a pleasure to be here,
and also,
nobody says "hipper" anymore.
-Oh, really? What do they say?
-Just "young."
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And just to be completely fair,
we've also invited
Jeff Wright's counterpart
to join this discussion.
Please also welcome Jeff Wrong.
-Hey, Seth!
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for having me.
People don't just say "young."
We say "young and splaaaa."
-I probably won't.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's get
down to business.
After being indicted
on racketeering charges,
Grammy-winning rapper
Young Thug's lyrics
are being cited as evidence
in the sweeping, 56-count
gang indictment,
again raising a debate
over whether lyrics
are protected free speech.
Jeff Wright,
what are your thoughts?
-I think it's unfair, Seth.
As much as we enjoy raps
about money, cars,
and unpaid child support,
a lot of it is just fabricated
and meant for entertainment.
It's not intended to be real.
Except maybe the unpaid
child support part.
[ Laughter ]
And we don't do this
to pop music.
I mean, Bruno Mars said
he'll catch a grenade.
That doesn't mean he wants
to be sent to war.
-Right. That is a fair point.
Jeff Wrong, your thoughts?
-Fair?
We should be holding everyone
responsible for their lyrics!
Foster the People said
in a song,
"run, run, run,
and outrun his gun."
Lock them up!
[ Laughter ]
Justin Bieber said
in a song that
he gets his weed from
California.
Sounds like drug trafficking
to me, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
Lock him up!
Freddie Mercury put in a song,
"Mama, just killed a man,"
and he told everyone
how he did it.
Lock him up!
And lock his mama up, too,
for not reporting it.
-Freddie Mercury is dead,
though.
-Well, that's what happens
when you go out
and just kill a guy!
[ Laughter ]
There's gonna be some blowback.
-Okay.
I see why they call you
Jeff Wrong.
In other news,
Kourtney Kardashian
and Travis Barker
got married in Italy.
Jeff Wright, your thoughts?
-Hey, I am happy for them, Seth.
Love is in the air.
However, it was
their third wedding,
and it's a little bit crazy
to be even
having one wedding
during COVID.
I just hope everyone
was vaxxed and boosted.
-Yeah, I didn't think
about it that way.
It is a little irresponsible
to have three weddings.
But you gotta be happy for them.
Jeff Wrong?
-No, you don't.
[ Laughter ]
Boo! We get it.
They love each other.
But why would you even have
a wedding in Italy
and have Andrea Bocelli perform
and have all these cool
celebrities come out with you?
-I don't know, Jeff Wrong.
You sound a little bit more like
Jeff Jealous.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm -- I'm not jealous.
You're jealous.
-Mm. Very mature.
Alright, lastly, after
a physical altercation
on a plane, Mike Tyson will not
face any criminal charges.
-And he shouldn't face
any charges.
I think he should find the guy
and beat his ass again.
-Now, wait a minute,
that opinion sounds wrong,
but you're Jeff Wright.
-Yes, because that opinion
is right.
Look, we all know what that guy
said to Tyson.
But if you're dumb enough to say
anything to Mike Tyson
in an enclosed space
like an airplane,
you probably deserve
a punch in the mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, now that guy has a story
he can tell
for the rest of his life.
-You make a compelling point.
Jeff Wrong?
-Hey, well,
he said what I was gonna say.
-Who did?
-I guess I did, Seth.
-Well, do you apologize to
Jeff Wrong?
-I mean...I'm sorry,
Jeff Wrong.
-And do you accept his apology?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
It's a simple question.
Do you accept his apology?
-I...Yeah. It's all good.
I mean, I might punch him
in the face.
-Alright. Jeff Wright, final
thoughts, Jeff Wright?
-Yeah.
-Final thoughts.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey --
-No, actually, you know what?
We have to go on with the show.
But thank you so much,
Jeff Wrong.
Goodbye, Jeff Wrong.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeff Wright and Jeff Wrong,
everybody.
We'll be right back.